if it seems like there are more sales
than usual it's because there are simply
these stores have too much stuff it's
been the talk of many retailers earnings
calls I would say there's going to be a
a a hesitate to call it a bloodbath but
it's going to be ugly uh in terms of
um the amount of discounting and
markdowns these big inventories aren't
just a good deal for your closet they're
a classic example of the bullwhip effect
here's why these stores have such large
inventories and what all these sales
mean for the economy
nothing shows the problem more clearly
than this chart it's the ratio between
inventories and sales for General
retailers places like Walmart or Macy's
for the last several years retailers
have been pretty good at keeping just a
bit more inventory than sales it's a
good balance of keeping enough stock on
hand to not have bare shelves but not
wasting money to store too much extra
inventory
and then of course covet happened
[Music]
but after a year of supply chain issues
the economy began to recover and
inventories got slightly back to normal
yet today it's like an echocardiogram
for a patient who goes into shock we had
really fast economic growth in 2021 and
part of that growth was building up
inventories and what a lot of companies
discovered was they built up too much
and in some cases they built up
inventories of the wrong stuff retail
experts say the build up is partly
because the stores wrongly planned that
consumers would keep up their pandemic
level spending and partly because of
that bullwhip effect
[Music]
think back to 2020 when demand for
athleisure wear was high stuck in
quarantine people stocked up on yoga and
sweatpants you know I'm kind of happy
with my target yoga pants lately working
from home so retailers placed more
orders for lounge apparel with the
wholesalers who then placed more orders
with the manufacturers to then Place
more orders with their suppliers the
further down the line This chain went
the demand got larger and larger
and by the time the pants could be
passed back down the line and fill the
racks at the stores the demand just
wasn't there they ordered stuff that
took a really long time to get there
because of all the supply chain issues
they had and then they discovered that
the stuff that they had ordered from the
overseas suppliers was no longer what a
lot of consumers wanted to buy replace
yoga pants with air fryers and big TVs
and add inflation which has caused
people to shift their spending the
inventory Bowl whips that we're seeing
are very uneven across Industries and
that's one of the reasons why inflation
is very uneven right now in the
mid-1900s inventories were a driver of
recessions mainly because a lot of
things were made in the U.S too much
inventory meant stores would Place fewer
orders so plants would slow production
the other side of the bullwhip when they
cut production they laid off workers
workers spent less we went into a
recession and you had this kind of
easily defined business cycle well so
because the economy has changed so much
because we import a lot of what we
consume from overseas because there's
these just in time inventories it's hard
to say how the bullwhip is gonna is
gonna play out this time instead of
hitting the United States hit other
countries like China China's economy is
really struggling right now and this
might be part of that story
so how should we feel about these sales
if everything is on sale is it good
because it could bring down inflation or
is it not good because businesses are
losing money which could lead into a
recession you know on the one hand uh
it's good it's good news for many
individuals because they get cheaper
stuff
in some ways it's good news for
businesses because they're clearing out
their inventories but it could also be
bad news because it's a process that can
feed on itself it could hurt corporate
profits it could drive down stock prices
this is the inherent tension in a
market-driven economy there's always two
hands these sales are likely to continue
throughout the year a reprieve from
inflation many Shoppers are eager to
take advantage of but the bullwhip
hasn't had its final snap yet
foreign